[Music]
Allah clarification you know it's good
or conclusion let me say conclusion the
guy is a blame World
debate speaking to him he's not
listening and remember Allah
mentioned so the when he TS to blame
where debat better off to walk away from
it the guy is not listening because I
was going to demonstrate to him the
criteria he mentioned go against his own
belief he got against against his own
belief he got because the New Testament
he got against against the Old Testament
the Old Testament teaches you God is not
a man but you have the new testament
which you believe as a Christian God
become a man also the Old Testament
teach you you are accountable for your
own sins the New Testament it teaches
you as you claim that Jesus died for
your sins the Old Testament teaches you
anyone that is hanged or crucified is
cursed and you believe Jesus became
cursed so Satan was righteous became
cursed Jesus was a righteous became
cursed therefore Christians you are
disrespecting our Mighty true Messiah
Jesus by making him equal to the Satan
by saying he became cursed Jesus was
holy he was not cursed look how Muslim
defend our Mighty messenger the Messiah
Jesus that's why Paul was the enemy of
Jesus that's why Jes Paul said Jesus
became cursed because of our sins just
to justify the the the belief ofes died
for your sins because he got and against
the Old Testament and I can go all on to
show you how many times the New
Testament got and against the Old
Testament as for the Quran the Old
Testament is not my criteria you
Christians believe the Old Testament is
criteria over your book but no that's
why the beauty of Islam Islam is not in
need of any other religion or scripture
to prove
Itself by Christianity without the Old
Testament you're dying that's why you
are leaking the foot of the yahood the
Jewish people because you have to go
about the old book that's why a lot of
you cannot come openly and condemn what
the Zionist are doing in Philistine
because you look at them as hi the
children of God you know recently have
you heard American guy what his name he
said that we should stand with the
So-Cal Israel because God told us in the
Bible